[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
just allow me to talk
[Music]
i was at costco the other day and
i was walking to my car and i was
thinking to myself
[Music]
gosh i hope i never get tired of these
triscuits
[Music]
and i hope i have seven years of
dandruff
i don't mean to be gross but i realize
the only time it's good to yell out i
have diarrhea
is when you're playing scrabble
[Music]
[Applause]
i rented a tom green movie last night
[Applause]
[Music]
and it's due back in march
[Music]
i was in chinatown today and i love
chinatown in new york it's my favorite
part of new york
but you know who is a really really good
chinatown
it's hong kong
it's huge
you know when you pick up migrant
workers just so you can ride in the
carpool lane
i have an old typewriter at my house
like a lot of people do it i'm going to
take it into a big computer store
and look at the guy behind the counter
and go uh i can't get this hooked up to
the internet
that was good
i want to plug a book that i wrote
that's coming out
it's a book about conjoined twins
they're joined at the tip of the nose
and it's called stop looking at me
now i'd like to do a character i've been
working on for a while
this character is called the simpleton
southern lady
i'm so mad at the taliban right now
[Applause]
[Music]
my name transf translated from greek to
is spanish a zamo
[Music]
for three years i've been addicted to uh
cold turkey
and i would tell people i'm quitting
cold turkey
you're like what are you quitting i'm
like cold turkey
thanksgiving's coming up
there's gonna be a lot of cold turkey
around the house
america heat up that cold turkey
heat up that cold turkey
thank you very much great job
thank god for not just everybody take a
break we'll be right back stick around